[Music]
doron
thank you for joining me in 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm great how are you good safe and
healthy and quarantined still
yeah actually i just arrived today back
home after two weeks
um actually camping
in my brother property in the north of
israel oh wow
it was the best quarantine uh ever
i think um beautiful so
for the last two weeks i lived in a tent
that's real oh so actual camping not
just you know outside okay
interesting i lived in a tent
um in a beautiful property with a small
stream in it wow yeah and the springtime
in israel now is beautiful
so i moved out of tel aviv and
you know all the corona situation
so you did it the intelligent way okay i
see where we're headed now
doron um you're an educator at heart
and by profession yet you're also an
innovator at heart and by profession
let's go back a a few years and talk to
me about
the education world and and how
you and and what and what you're trying
to what you did
to pave your way through there
so well the education world is
is very wide as you know but um
my first real step in this world was in
the israel innovation institute after
you know writing a lot of content before
and do a lot of stuff
but the combination between education
and innovation started in the israel
innovation institute which is a very
interesting initiative here in israel
trying to implement innovation into the
public sector
it's a great challenge i think like we
have a lot of innovation and
great solutions out there but it doesn't
reach most of the society
like nowadays we really see it and we
really understand needs
um but we dealt with the like the basic
needs of a real a big society
the public um i mean transportation
you know ecomotion community be well
for help and also education
so i was the head of the education part
and we work with the government to
implement innovation into the
educational
system of israel which is really not
easy
yeah both you know it sounds not easy
both on the front of
trying to innovate a an educative system
that's been around for hundreds of years
and at the same time doing so within a
government that is innately
supposed to be a blocker and a very
bureaucratic
right so that's that's you know that
these are the reasons why why why it's
so hard
right but um
when we started to talk about education
which you know it's it's a huge
system yeah we started to to bring
new terms into this world
so we used to say education but we use
more learning
and we try to bring more um terms
and ideas from the world outside into
the
education system right the environment
and to create
new environments for for the system
so what does that actually mean tangibly
yeah so what what does it mean new
environments and learning environments
uh
in this time um there's a lot to say
but first is to understand the let's say
the major principles of
learning and education and and
i think this is how to
promote curiosity creativity
and you know um
whatever we all see outside with in the
startup world
we wanted to bring it into the
educational world and the learning
environments
and we wanted to show that we don't need
to talk anymore about education
as we know this term but to
try to let's say bring the the
real world the reality into schools
yeah and this way
and that's mean um when we're outside as
entrepreneurs looking
around we're looking for um problems we
can call it or
challenges to solve and i'm sure we want
to do
different things we want to do good and
we want to to to earn money and to
to grow right and together so
so bring different um interests together
and also different disciplines right you
don't
you don't need um physics or math or
only uh computer science
or you need different people designers
visioners
uh scientists you need different systems
and you need to learn how to
to work together um so what were some of
the things that were implemented
as a result of this you know this
innovative and creative thinking
around education are there some things
that went on
to actually go into the education system
or any experiments that were done in
schools
to to show potential uh results
ask if we if we did so well i i just
want to
get some some better idea of more
tangibly what it means
to change the classroom because you know
obviously in talking broadly about it
yeah
it's incredibly difficult but how do you
actually go about and do it so what what
actually
happened there so i will bring
i would raise few few examples because
you know there are so many
different ways and and and and solutions
but uh
um we started to do uh hackathons
now we all know what is it but
like seven years ago yes it was a
beginning or
five years six years ago it was the very
beginning right
especially for teenagers teenagers
and we saw how it works well outside and
you know with corporates or
other um companies and organizations and
we said to ourselves
why not inside schools so this great
talents in school they do nothing with
their all their creativity
you know they're just trying to remember
and learn
what they hear from the teachers sure
and
with this experiment with the teenagers
and we invited them during the summer
vacation
which which is something that you you
don't want to mess with you don't want
to touch it
right yeah it's the time of of a
teenager don't don't try to push
anything into it um
and we invited them to to to join a
hackathon dealing with
challenges of young people
during the summer it can be drugs it can
be
driving it can be learning it can be
volunteering whatever name it right
and we don't you know we didn't have any
expectations
um and then we you know
we did some work and we were really
surprised to get more than 160
participants you know more registered
but um
a lot a lot of people and
we just we we
find there's so many creative and
amazing
um uh solutions from this young people
right and then it got a lot of the
attention you know
pr whatever it is
and then more schools and and
and people asked us to to to do the same
yeah uh and then we started to work on
with this the idea of challenge inside
schools
and we show them that first every
every student every kid can
can be part of it they all have
different skills and then
and expertise that they can that they
can share and
and support with sure
and but also um you know just
start so yeah so going from education
you it sounds like there were sort of
these you know philosophies that started
accumulating about what it means to
to think about education more broadly
not just as math science humanities but
also what does it mean that we're trying
to
to get people to be global thinkers and
innovators and
professionals mature then you took it on
and you continued it into the more tech
world
and you went on to mass challenge and
and joined
jvp and and founded some things there so
tell me a little bit about
how you transition from education and
what are some of the things that you
took with you
as you went into the other industries
um so it's a great question when i was
at the step
thinking what i'm gonna what i want to
do next after
uh this the israel innovation institute
you know
we all want to move fast and to grow and
to
have different experiences and
everything and
i had this question do i want to be very
very focused
on education or learning or i want to
learn my
you know myself and to go try different
things
and to be more open right and that's
what i believe
should should happen in the educational
world in the learning um
in schools and so i decided to
to move on to mass challenge which is a
global organization
it's a it's a non-profit but working in
different disciplines and verticals
right with hundreds and thousands of
entrepreneurs around the world
yeah uh and i think it was a very very
interesting step for me
um being more open open my my world
sure uh not staying at the same square
um but maybe before you know years back
when i started education and philosophy
and also i had a short
episode and in that sale for
architecture yeah
yeah so you know very dynamic
and that's that's the world
um and and my first uh my first role my
first
position in this world was when i saw
a position in the jerusalem
institute and it was for the department
of innovation in economy
i had no clue in this world not
innovation
and not economy but i was very curious
about this job it looked very very
interesting yeah and excited you know
i have no chance to get there but why
not try like just
write an email and write them you know
check my
um my cv because it's not it doesn't fit
your
your needs yeah but i'm very interested
in this role because of
blah blah blah blah they were probably
very surprised of
getting in this email um and so they
invited me for an interview
and i got this job wow
that was the very beginning and i'm
always remember it
because you know it was so not when you
see
something and you you ask yourself
is that for me or do i have any chance
to to get
to get into it and into this job
whatever position
company organization or university
is it sounds very basic but then you
have the no in your hands
so whatever you'll do now can bring can
can bring you closer to the yes right
and and i think if i if i
i'll take it back to our days in the
corona time
we're all in kind of a risk and and so
we
we have the opportunity to try new
things right
um so after going back to myself
after mass challenge i moved to a vc i
wanted to
to understand the world of entrepreneur
from this side
so always as an investor we ask yourself
you know we look on investors and we ask
do they know what we feel as
entrepreneurs
do they or they're just up there
holding the money and yeah you know
trying to to do the right uh choice
and i said if i want to be a real
entrepreneur i also want to learn this
aspect of a phd
for a very like
nice period also doing a lot of
collaboration with global uh
like multinationals uh companies and and
israeli startups and now
just as i told you before uh in the
summer i decided to
quit to take some time for myself
and to see what i want to do with all
this
experience and expertise and what's my
next step
yeah and it was very fitting because it
was just before it was just before
everybody had to take a break but yours
was an induced one
uh so it's a it's a very interesting
coincidence and you mentioned that you
were actually
one of the one of the first to go on the
new york subway with the hand sanitizer
and before coming back to israel doron
what are some of the
you know for somebody who comes out
who doesn't come from the education
world and hasn't worked with governments
and
really you know big picture stuff what
what are some of the biggest challenges
that you faced
when on one hand running innovation in
in education on the other hand you have
to at the end pitch it and
discuss it with with government
officials
and you know education is so sensitive
and it's such a
you know it's such a is i would say
small bubble where you don't want to
to you don't want to touch it because
you're because then you're dealing with
kids
and you're dealing with an
infrastructure of a country
so what are some of the challenges that
you faced over there
so it's it's it's a very good question
um
the first challenge challenge is just to
bring them to the table
um and i think
this kind of of systems they like to
join
success stories they like to join
success
to convince them to join before it's
really hard yeah
not talking not talking about i'll
convince them to put some money
okay that's much that's
it yeah yeah that's a that's a dream
that's uh
but just to join this and to take the
risk of joining something trying
something new
so we that's why we did this first
hackathon
without their um you know we invited
them to join
but they didn't do need to do anything
it's
just just to come and see just to come
and look right okay we didn't
anything from them um
and then once they saw it's
the success they
they they said okay how how do we bring
this
into our places um so
i think you need and also you need to
show them that you don't need anything
from them
at the beginning you just want to come
that makes sense
you just want to come and help um and
also we brought
other sectors with us so it wasn't just
this
non-profit the israel innovation
institute institute that thinks that
they know everything
yeah we brought up we brought more
entrepreneurs
investors um you know
great success people really
around the country from different uh
industries
yeah we showed the the educational
system
and the government that you know it's
not
only our interest or our motivation
it's it's from all over right and
everybody wants to help in this
topic so it's it's important for
for the high tech it's important for
other industries
it's important for universities they all
want to be part of
and to support this change so
we're all coming together to help you
like the the government to to do
something and we don't want to change
the whole world
just step by step to show you some
principles that we use out there
uh and how it can uh improve and promote
your system and once with
this way like speak you know we spoke
a new language and show them it's not a
monster
then it was just
um definitely i think a lot more to do
in this in this area but that was a
a a very good beginning and i think
we saw more and more schools um
organizations and we had more um open
doors in the government to
to do some changes sure and we got more
money from the government that was
um an achievement for
so you know the wrong maybe in one
minute just paint me a picture of how
would you
imagine the education uh
atmosphere i don't know 10 years from
now so let's say
when my kids go to elementary school or
middle school
what are they going to what are what
should they experience
if you were to to to lead these
different
transformations
so i think 10 years it's it's too far um
so let's say even um five six years
um but i think they will be able to
choose much much more
okay so a very important term
now in the educational systems is person
personalization yep like
in all other systems but what does it
mean it means a lot but it means
that the way we measure learning
will be totally different sure
so you would be you'll be able to learn
in the way that
you okay uh or me as the one
used to learn and we learn in different
ways
so nowadays we have 30 35 kids in a
class
right and so the teacher need to be
focused on the
the the middle yep different age
edges the really really good ones
yeah and those that's you know reaching
the the
the class but there is no reason for
that
so now we have all the technology that
can support
learning um um
processes sure for death
and help them to choose the way
they can learn definitely yeah i think
something we will see more of that
um you know i i would like to say we'll
see
opening uh schools no classrooms
whatever
and there are some students like this in
the world if you know them
steve jobs schools you heard it i did
not hear about it
no steve jobs schools it's actually
just me using the name of steve jobs
but um it's it's found it started in in
in holland okay
and it's something really really
interesting uh
so no no real classrooms no
like mix of ages and things
um but it's hard to
to implement it in a big system
right so i think we'll you know
personalization in in education would be
i'd i definitely agree and i actually
i'm i know i i'm
friends with the cell can here and and
he has the khan labs school
from k to 12 which is a very
personalized school it's not
i'm not sure how scalable it is because
the personalization comes with the cost
of personnel and staff and and and very
expensive technology
but you definitely see incredible
results that are showing so i'm very
excited to see
you know how my kids and the next
generation will will then
go to school and but there's some time
for that so it's okay uh
you're gonna be fancy you know you look
you're looking five for 10 years
forward definitely definitely the wrong
yeah before we finish i have to ask you
the most important question
what are three words that you would best
describe yourself as
or if i would ask any of your colleagues
whether they're from the education or
jvp or mass challenge
how would they describe their own in
three words
so i would say dynamic
creative and
[Music]
i want to say as a word people
it's all about it's all about the people
i love it
doron you join a company or a startup
just
first pick the people i love it jerome
thank you so much for the time
thank you very much great for inviting
me
and of course take care
looking forward to good times definitely
yeah they will come